aujourd'hui une vidéo un petit peu
particulière je vais sortir de mes
habitudes puisque je ne vais pas parler
d'un philosophe mais david le mythe
d'adam et eve et et du péché originel
alors j'ai bien conscience que en
employant le mot mythe je risque de
froisser certaines susceptibilités
notamment celle de personnes qui
considèrent que l'histoire d'adam et eve
n'est pas un mythe mais mais une réalité
donc je précise immédiatement que je ne
situe absolument pas dans cette
problématique
je ne pose pas la question de savoir si
adam et eve ont effectivement existé je
m'interroge sur cet épisode d'un point
de vue seulement en philosophie kg c'est
de savoir ce qu'il peut y avoir à
retenir dans cet épisode ce qu'il peut y
avoir à à en apprendre et savoir en quoi
cette ce mythe peut nous aider à
comprendre un peu mieux notre monde et
et notre condition
alors je vais faire un petit rappel donc
le mythe d'adam et eve provient de la
genèse de la bible ancien testament et
il fait suite donc au récit de la
création de l'univers donc dieu créé
l'univers est le sixième jour et il créé
l'homme
adam alors à dents et créer nous dit la
genèse à partir de la poussière de la
terre à partir de là de la glaise adam
donc la signification de la danse est
celui qui est issu de la terre c'est le
les oeufs littéralement en fait à partir
de la glaise il nous est dit l'éternel
format l'homme de la poussière de la
terre il souffla dans ses narines un
souffle de vie et l'homme devint un être
vivant
alors je fais simplement remarqué
quelque chose sur le plan étymologique à
danser le masculin de adama qui signifie
la terre ce qui confirme donc l'idée que
adam c'est celui qui vient de la terre
s'est littéralement le terrestre ou le
terrien et si on pousse la métaphore on
peut dire que adam étant le masculin de
la terre il est en quelque sorte le mari
de la terre et c'est intéressant d'avoir
cette approche puisque ça nous permet de
comprendre
le rôle historique de l'homme sur la
terre qui est un rôle offensif donc qui
serait associé symboliquement à la
polarité masculine tandis que la terre
elle est ce qu'ils produisent
naturellement les ressources
on parle d'ailleurs de dame nature pour
pour exprimer cette cette abondance de
la terre abondance de la terre que
l'homme va exploiter à son profit
donc adam est l'homme de la terre le
principe mal tandis que la terre elle
même serait le principe femelle la
nature à danser l'homme de la terre
c'est celui qui est issu de l'humus donc
l'humus et l'humain sont ici en relation
et adam ce n'est pas l'homme en tant qu
individu masculin seulement à danser
l'homme générique c'est l'homme avec un
grand h se souvient qu avec platon on
avait parlé de cette idée de l'homme
avec un grand h
l'homme générique qui est au delà de la
division sexuelle qui représente l'être
humain en général
hommes et femmes confondus voilà pour
adam qu'en est il des ve eve nous dit la
genèse est tiré de la côte d'adam ou de
son côté tout dépend des traductions
puisque cote et côté sont là aussi en
relation fc donc le côté femelle d'adam
et eve signifie la vie je précise que
adam et eve sont également nommés riche
et ich à -sh aïcha on voit bien on voit
bien que ce sont les mêmes mots et que
l'un est au féminin et l'autre au
masculin
ça nous rappelle donc adam est bien
l'homme générique le modèle de
l'humanité tandis que riesch
ce serait la partie masculine d'adam et
icha eve serait la partie féminine
d'adam au départ adam est donc à la fois
homme et femme il est donc une totalité
une totalité qui contient en lui les
deux polarités c'est ce qui permet de
comprendre que adam a été créé à l'image
de dieu puisque dieu des lui-même ni mal
ni femelle en tant qu être parfait il
est les deux à la fois et adam en tant
qu'être générique est à la fois homme et
femme
il est au delà de la division sexuelle
il est donc de ce point de vue là à
l'image de dieu on peut ici fait
référence dayoro au mythe des androgynes
qui nous est
racontée dans le banquet de platon ou
nous explique que à l'origine des hommes
à l'origine de l'humanité
il y a les androgynes qui sont des
créatures qui sont à la fois aux hommes
et femmes qui sont des créatures total
parfaite et que c'est d'ailleurs parce
qu' elle étai des créatures achevé
qu'elle était doté d'une extraordinaire
puissance qu'elles ont voulu se
confronter aux dieux et que zeus pour
les en empêcher a cherché à les
affaiblir en les coupant en deux et
c'est de là qu'est née la division
sexuelle entre les hommes et les femmes
donc revenons sur le récit le récit du
péché tel qu'il nous est racontée dans
la jeunesse adam et eve vivent dans le
jardin d'éden
et dans ce jardin tout est à profusion
il ne manque de rien ils n'ont pas
besoin de travailler pour vivre ils
vivent dans l'insouciance totale du
lendemain et pour le temps n'existe pas
dans ce jardin où il n'ya aucune
contrainte
il y a une chose qu'ils n'ont pas le
droit de faire c'est de goûter au fruit
de l'arbre de la connaissance du bien et
du mal le fameux fruit défendu et
l'éternel leur dit vous pouvez manger
des fruits de tous les arbres sauf de
celui de cet arbre car alors vous
m'aurez donc la sanction et est annoncé
et l'interdît est clairement formulée
adam et eve n'ont pas le droit de goûter
du fruit défendu du fruit de l'arbre de
la connaissance du bien et du mal
c'est alors que eve fait la rencontre
avec le serpent qui lui dit que dieu
m'en est que si goût de ce fruit ne
mourront pas mais que leurs yeux
s'ouvriront leurs yeux s'ouvriront ils
seront les égaux des dieux d'ailleurs on
dit bien les durs on ne dit pas les ego
de dieu c'est intéressant de noter en
passant
que fait m elle va se laisser aux
convaincre par le serpent elle va goûter
le fruit et elle va le tendre à adam qui
lui aussi va croquer le fruit à ce
moment-là adam s'aperçoit qu'il est nu
et il en a honte
il se cache à l'éternel et l'éternel
comprend qu adam et eve ont goûté le
fruit il le comprend parce que s'il ya
dans ce cas âge c'est parce qu'il a
honte
et si la honte c'est parce qu'il a pris
conscience de sa nullité
alors la sanction ne se bat attendre
c'est l'expulsion du jardin d'éden et
l'éternel prononce donc ces phrases qui
reste assez célèbre il dit à attendre tu
gagneras ton pain à la sueur de ton
front et à eve tu enfanteras dans la
douleur quant aux serpents et les
maudits il est condamné à ramper ce qui
signifie qu'ils ne rentrent pas avant
qu'il n'avait donc pas là la forme du
serpent tel qu'on le connaît et nous ai
dit tu marcheras sur ton ventre et tu
mangeras de la poussière tous les jours
de ta vie que la fonction qui est
infligé aux serpents
c'est de se trouver au haut niveau
d'existence le plus le plus bas il
devient l'un des êtres les plus bas dans
l'échelle de l'être puisqu'il est le
plus en contact avec la terre c'est à
dire avec la matière et la matière dans
la religion chrétienne est souvent
associée allons faire alors comment
peut-on interpréter ce qui arrive à adam
et eve que leur arrive-t-il exactement
mais déjà il ya un problème c'est que
dieu les avertit que si tu goût du fruit
de l'arbre de la connaissance du bien et
du mal
ils mourront or il ne meurt pas ils ne
sont pas condamnés à mort ils sont
expulsés du jardin d'éden
donc ils sont condamnés à la souffrance
pas la mort eve est condamné a enfanté
dans la douleur
et qu'est-ce que l'enfantement est bien
quand on dit d'une femme qu'elle est en
train d'accoucher ou peut elle commence
à coucher hongrie le travail a commencé
lorsqu'on parle du travail qui vient du
mot latin tripalium qui signifie
l'instrument torture on parle bien d'une
souffrance et l'enfantement est
effectivement une souffrance c'est une
souffrance
physique c'est une souffrance qui
concerne le monde de la matérialité et
cette souffrance
elle est la condition de la reproduction
du cycle vital sur la terre loeb se
reproduit mais c'est la femme qui met au
monde et en mettant au monde
elle s'offre la souffrance et le moyen
de la perpétuation de l'espèce humaine
dans le temps l'homme lui doit
travailler et gagner son pain à la sueur
de son front
ici le travail n'est pas un travail de
reproduction mais un travail de
production
c'est le travail du labeur c'est le
labour au sens de l'activité de la terre
le travail de la terre
et là aussi ce travail s'accomplit dans
la souffrance travaillé à la sueur de
son front la sueur et en l'indicatif de
la souffrance
pourquoi cette souffrance pour produire
et pour extraire les ressources vitales
là encore il s'agit de perpétuer le
cycle vital alors pourquoi est ce que
l'éternel a dit à adam et eve qu'il
mourrait s'il goûte est le fruit bien en
fait il n'a pas dit qu'il mourrait
instantanément ce qu'on peut comprendre
c'est qu'ils sont plongés dans une
dimension la dimension matérielle à
l'intérieur de laquelle ils vont
connaître la mort cette dimension c'est
la dimension de la matière et du temps
puisque la matière et le temps sont
totalement relié
il n'y a pas de matière son temps et le
temps n'existe qu'à partir du moment où
apparaît la matière quand est ce qu est
né le temps il est né au moment du big
bang c'est à dire au moment du
jaillissement de la matière dans
l'univers
donc adam et eve ne meurt pas
instantanément ils sont expulsés du
jardin d'éden qui est un un dieu en
dehors du temps ils sont plongés dans la
matière dans laquelle ils vont connaître
l'expérience de la mort ils sont
expulsés dans la matière donc ils sont
condamnés à travailler pour survivre
que ce soit par le travail de la terre
qui va leur procurer leur leurs
ressources alimentaires ou que ce soit
par le travail de l'accouchement qui
permet à l'homme de se perpétuer non pas
dans sa propre existence
mais dans les générations futures c'est
donc la perpétuation de l'espèce à
travers la reproduction
adam et eve sont donc condamnés à faire
l'expérience des lois de la matière
parmi lesquels le principe de génération
la loi de la reproduction travailler
pour survivre cultiver produire et c'est
adam lèvres sont propulsés dans la
matière ils sont donc propulsés dans le
temps si le temps n'existait pas il n'y
aurait ni l'essence ni mort ce serait
l'éternité
d'ailleurs dieu et en os mais l'éternel
on comprend par là que il se situe hors
du temps il ne naît pas il ne meurt pas
il les lettres est au delà du devenir et
c'est parce que la matière existe que le
temps existe puisque ce qui existe dans
le temps a forcément un commencement une
fin
c'est donc le temps qui les tuera c'est
le temps qui tuera adam et eve
c'est le temps également qui les fera
souffler ans il les fera souffrir
puisque la survie dans le dans
présuppose le travail la souffrance ici
on peut faire une petite référence au
poème de charles baudelaire qui a pour
titre l'ennemi avec un e majuscule et
baudelaire explique bien dans ce poème
que l'ennemi c'est précisément le temps
que le temps nous fait souffrir
il nous fait souffrir parce qu'ils
limitent notre existence à l'intérieur
de deux bornes temporel dont nous ne
pouvons pas sortir
il nous fait souffrir parce que notre
esprit est constamment obsédé par l'idée
de la mort qui est l'idée de la fin et
il est également pris par le passé à
travers la nostalgie et le regret et
veut dire que l'existence matérielle est
une existence nécessairement source d
angoisse
elle est source d'angoissé dès lors
qu'elle s'accompagne de la conscience
puisque la conscience ou fait comprendre
que nous ne sommes pas immortels
la mort est la conséquence du temps
c'est toute la différence qu'il ya entre
l'existence et la vie on se rappelle de
cette distinction faite par platon
l'existence et est liée au monde
sensible est lié au monde de la matière
tandis que la vie c'est le processus
général qui est au delà de la matière et
du traverse les individus donc à quoi
adam et eve sont ils condamnés eh bien
ils sont condamnés à la chute
la chute dans la matière la chute dans
le monde sensible de platon ce qui peut
là aussi nous être confirmée par le fait
qu il nous est dit dieu leur donna des
vêtements de peau des vêtements de pot
ça signifie qu'avant ça ils n'avaient
pas de pot donc s'il n'avait pas de pot
c'est qu'il n'avait pas de corps il se
situer donc dans un monde qui n'était
pas lui-même matériel ils sont chassés
du paradis du jardin d'éden
le rapprochement entre le jardin d'éden
et le paradis peut être discutée mais on
parle ici d'un lieu qui est hors du
temps des lieux dans lequel on est au
près du créateur et on ne connaît pas la
souffrance ni la mort on est bien
au-delà du monde sensible on est bien
dans une dimension supérieure images de
la chute s'est donc l'image d'une
dégradation de l'être une dégradation de
l'offre générique qui d'un état originel
de plénitude et de rapports immédiats à
l'être d'immanence pur va tomber eva
déchoir dans une dimension inférieure
qui est la dimension du temps de la
matière et de la souffrance
remarquons ce qu'il se passe lorsque
adam goûte le fruit il se voit nue il en
a honte
qu'est ce que ça veut dire mais ça veut
dire que la honte c'est l'entrée dans le
monde de la représentation
c'est entrer dans le monde de l'image de
l'image de soi puisque avoir honte de sa
nudité
ça suppose d'adopter le regard extérieur
de celui qui nous voit nue
on n'a pas honte d'être nues lorsqu'on
est tout seul on n'a pas honte d'être nu
lorsque personne ne regarde on a honte
d'être nu à partir du moment où l'on
sait que quelqu'un d'autre peut nous
voir mieux et que l'on ne souhaite pas
que ce soit le cas il ya donc une
préoccupation du regard d'autrui du
regard qui est porté sur nous qui va
faire qu'on va éprouver un sentiment de
honte
ce qui veut dire qu'il ne peut y avoir
de honte qu à partir du moment où il ya
représentation de soi à travers le
regard d'autrui
à partir du moment où il y à une
dissociation de soi vis-à-vis de soi
c'est pour ça qu'on peut parler d'une
sortie de l'immanence de lettres et d'un
processus de de distanciation vis-à-vis
de soi et de divisions intérieures
c'est le monde la conscience de soi
c'est le moment où l'on commence à
s'appréhender soi même du point de vue
d'autrui
ce qui n'était pas le cas avant que adam
goûte le fruit il était dans dans un
rapport immédiat à l'être et à partir du
moment où ils où il s'éveille à la
connaissance c'est là qu'il prend
conscience de la division c'est là qu'il
opère cette séparation vis-à-vis de
lui-même qui est à la fois un acte de
conscience mais aussi un acte de
représentation et de pub habilité la
genèse nous dit il goûte r le fruit est
alors ils connurent qu'ils étaient nus
et l'éternel dit à adam qui t'a appris
que tu étais nul alors à dents il n'est
pas l'oubli n'est pas totalement
totalement stupide il voit bien qu'il
est nu donc ça veut dire qu'il avait
peut-être les yeux fermés et à voir les
yeux fermés
c'est peut-être ce qui veut dire qu'il
était dans l'ignorance l'ignorance du
bien et du mal il a précisément accéder
à la connaissance du bien du mal mais le
fait est que même si il voyait qu'il
était nu ça signifie qu'il ignorait
jusqu'à lors la signification de la
nudité
quand je pars de la signification je
parle de la signification morale mentale
du fait d'être nu ils ignoraient tout
simplement la distinction entre la chair
et l'esprit et ça peut se comprendre
puisque si on admet l'hypothèse selon
laquelle le jardin d'éden n'est pas un
monde soumis à la matérialité et bien
adam et eve ne vivait tout simplement
pas dans la matière ils ont pris
conscience de la dimension matérielle
lorsqu'ils ont goûté le fruit et c'est
avec cette prise de conscience qui est
apparu le phénomène de la dissociation
et de la représentation et d'ailleurs
rappelez-vous dans la bible le christ
dit heureux les simples d'esprit et sa
entend donner une interprétation en
rapport avec le péché originel le simple
d'esprit ce n'est pas l'idiot ce n'est
pas la baisse' il quoique le mot
imbéciles j'ai fait une petite recherche
justement pour pour pouvoir en parler
l'imbécile
étymologiquement c'est celui qui est
sans béquilles la béquille et en
l'allégorie de la connaissance sur
laquelle on peut s'appuyer pour évoluer
pour avancer la culture ce serait là la
béquille de l'être et s'il a la
connaissance et la béquille de lettres
l'imbécile c'est celui qui n'a pas
béquille c'est peut-être celui qui n'a
pas besoin de la connaissance pour être
dans un rapport émanant à l'être si vous
préférez le simple d'esprit c'est celui
qui ne se pose pas la question puisqu'il
est dans un rapport immédiat à l'être et
la nudité ne lui pose pas de problème
aux simples d'esprit parce que pour lui
il n'y a pas de honte à avoir d'une
situation naturelle
il n'y a pas de honte à avoir d' une
sorte d'évidence de l'être puisque la
nudité c'est l'évidence de l'être on ne
naît pas habillé avoir honte de sa
nudité c'est ne plus être dans l'unité
de l'être c'est être passé du côté de
l'actualité de ce processus de
séparation du nez l'image la
représentation mais alors on peut se
poser la question pourquoi avoir goûter
le fruit si adam et eve étaient dans ce
rapport immédiat et spontanée à l'être
qu'est ce qui a fait qu'ils ont éprouvé
le besoin et le désir de goûter ce fruit
comme si il y avait une insatisfaction
qui était à l'origine de cette curiosité
pourquoi aller vers quelque chose si
rien ne leur manquait pourquoi désirer
quelque chose quand on a tout ce qu'on
veut c'est peut-être qu'il y avait une
insatisfaction cette évidence que
l'évidence est que l'immanence pure ne
leur suffisait pas et qu'il y avait un
désir d'en savoir plus ce qu'il y avait
un désir d'aller au delà de cette
évidence alors c'est peut-être un péché
d'orgueil ce que saint-augustin appelle
la la concupiscence est en tout cas ce
besoin ce désir était prêté présent chez
adam et eve
bien qu'il n'avait pas conscience qu'à
ce moment-là il commettait quelque chose
de mal pour eux la curiosité n'était pas
quelque chose de mal
tout simplement parce qu'ils ignoraient
ce qu'était le mal ce qui était la
notion de mal ils ignoraient la
distinction même entre le bien et le mal
et à partir du moment où il n'ya pas de
distinction entre le bien et le mal où
tout est dans dans l'immanence et
l'évidence pur la question se pose même
pas donc ici on a un parallèle très
nette avec les dan nature chez rousseau
où l'homme nous dit rousseau dans l'état
de nature
il n'est ni bon ni mauvais puisqu'il se
pose même pas la question il est dans
dans l'obéissance spontanée aux lois
naturelles et c'est seulement quand ils
entrent dans l'état civil dans l'état
social c'est-à-dire quand il se met à
vivre avec d'autres qu'apparaît la
distinction du bien et du mal et
qu'apparaît le monde
représentations lorsqu'on passe à l'état
social on n'est plus seul
on n'est plus donc dans l'état naturel
et originelle de notre condition on
n'est plus dans la nudité
on est dans l'apparence la comparaison
la concurrence la représentation et ce à
partir de ce moment là que va naître la
distinction entre le bien le mal entre
ce qui se fait ce qui ne se fait pas
entre ce que l'on peut faire et ce que
l'on doit pas faire donc je disais la
phrase du christ heureux les simples
d'esprit confirme cette idée puisque
simple d'esprit ça veut dire qu'ils ne
se posent pas de questions inutiles
simple ça veut dire qu'il n'est composée
que d'un seul élément art opposition à
compliquer compliqué c'est ce qui
composait de plusieurs éléments
adam est simple d'esprit lorsqu'il ne se
pose pas la question de la signification
de son état et de sa lucidité par
exemple il est simple d'esprit quand il
est dans un rapport direct et immédiat à
l'être il est simple d'esprit quand il
n'a pas besoin de se poser la question
du regard d'autrui pour savoir ce qu'il
est et par opposition il devient
compliqué son esprit se complexifie à
partir du moment où ils se disent ceci
lui-même à partir du moment où s'opère
une sorte de bifurcation intérieur et à
partir du moment où se pose la question
de l'image qu'il renvoie et où il entre
dans le monde du mental quel péché
ont-ils commis à dans l île ont commis
le péché d'avoir rompu l'unité ils ont
commis le péché d'avoir rompu cette
fusion originel avec l'être dans un
jardin d'éden qui ne connaissaient ni
division ni dualité ni pluralité où tout
est un où tout va de soi on ne se pose
pas de questions où le mental n'a pas sa
place où le mental n'a rien à faire sauf
à avoir été sciemment introduit dans le
jardin d'éden
et si le serpent représente le mental
c'est à dire s'il représente la division
à séparation la représentation il a été
placé dans le jardin d'éden pour qu adam
et eve le connaissent les déplacer là
pour kde enlève puisse faire
l'expérience de la division leurs péchés
a donc été de rompre l'unité
on ne se pose pas de questions quand
tout va de soi on ne se pose pas de
question d'en limiter
on se pose des questions à partir du
moment où il y
séparation où il y à distance entre le
sujet et l'objet
mais s'il n'ya pas d'objets il n'y a pas
de sujet s'il n'ya pas d'objets penser
il n'y a pas de pensée
donc on ne se pose pas de questions on
commence à s'interroger quand il ya
matière à s'interroger la pensée
commence avec la dualité le mois qu'ils
pensent et la chose qu'ils aient pensé
ce qui veut dire que la dualité
c'est une perte au sens où c'est une
perte de l'unité par définition
lorsqu'on a besoin par exemple de
formuler quelque chose de le
matérialiser avec des mots ça veut dire
qu'il ne relève plus d'une évidence ça
veut donc dire qu'on a perdu l'évidence
et l'immédiateté de la chose qu'on
exprime exprimer quelque chose c'est la
faire sortir de nous si on la fait
sortir de nous ça veut dire qu'on a
besoin de l'avoir exprimé qu'on a besoin
de l'avoir formules et donc que c'est
opérer une une fragmentation à
l'intérieur la dualité est une perte
et pourtant c'est aussi un gain est ce
que c'est le gain de l'intelligence qui
peut saisir
rétrospectivement ce qui est contenu
dans l'unité voyez que on peut avoir une
lecture qui ne soit pas axiologique qui
ne soit pas basée sur un jugement de
valeur de ce passage de l'unité à la
dualité
l'unité est un état d'immanence puant
qu'on peut considérer comme étant une
sorte d'âge d'or idéal mais d'un certain
point de vue le monde la dualité c'est
le monde de ce qui permet de faire
retour sur l'unité pour la saisir la
comprendre et la réinscrire dans un
schéma général
la dualité n'est pas le contraire de
l'unité elle est ce que contient l'unité
et lorsque le serpent dit si vous goûtez
le fruit vous serez comme des dieux
connaissez et vous serez comme des dieux
ça signifie bien que la connaissance des
dieux ne se limite pas à cette
immédiateté du rapport à l'être mais que
cette connaissance contient bien la
dimension mentale
c'est à dire la forme divisé de cette
unité
le propre de la dualité c'est de rompre
l'évidence et la dualité c'est ce qui
donne naissance au possible le possible
c'est ce qui peut être fait par
distinction de ce qui est de manière
immédiate est évidente
à partir du moment où il ya dualité il
ya possibilité il ya possibilité de ne
plus suivre ce qui paraissait évident ce
qui paraissait normal ou naturels et dès
lors qu'il ya possibilité il ya
possibilité du mal en fait
le mal n'est rien d'autre que la
possibilité du mal et qu'est ce qui fait
la différence qu est ce qui fait que
l'on peut passer de la possibilité du
mal au mal lui-même bien c'est le libre
arbitre
c'est le choix fait par tout un chacun
d'envisager cette possibilité et de la
concrétiser
par exemple lorsque l'éternel dit adam
et eve vous pouvez écouter tous les
fruits sauf celui de la connaissance du
bien et du mal
il établit dualité ne dualité entre ce
qui est interdit c'est à dire le fruit
de la connaissance
ce qui est autorisé c'est à dire tout le
reste il crée donc une une séparation il
crée donc une une division interne est
nécessairement de manière négative
il met en valeur ce qui est interdit
puisque ce qui est interdit c'est ce qui
ressort c'est ce qui est mis en relief
par rapport à tout le reste qui n'est
pas interdite l'interdît et dont quelque
chose qui nous attire nécessairement
puisque c'est ce qui ressort du champ de
tout ce qui est permis et adam et eve ne
pouvait qu'être attiré par par l'arbre
de la connaissance du bien et du mal
puisque cet arbre c'était ce qui
ressortait du reste cet arbre c'est la
flèche qui pointe l'endroit où où on n'a
pas le droit de regarder et qui fait que
précisément on va regarder c'est comme
si je vous disais essayé de ne pas
penser à un cheval blanc belle à la
plupart d'entre eux mots vous avez pensé
un cheval blanc à partir du moment où je
vous dis de ne pas faire quelque chose
et que cette interdiction ressort d'un
de tout un champ de permission et bien
c'est cette interdiction là qui va vous
attirer ce qui pose la question est ce
que le mal d'un point de vue biblique
ce ne serait pas la possibilité elle
même d'ailleurs c'est ce que disait
st pierre damien un théologien du
moyen-âge qui pensaient que la pluralité
était nécessairement diabolique tandis
que l'unité seul était divine et ça se
comprend sûr sur le plan conceptuel
si on dit que dieu c'est l'unité bien
c'est l'unité du rapport à l'être
immédiat c'est l'unité de la condition
d'adam et eve dans le jardin d'éden
c'est l'unité du paradis dans le dans
lequel l'amour la lumière la vérité ne
font qu'un tandis que la pluralité c'est
le monde de la division c'est le monde
de ce qui nous distingue c'est le monde
de ce qui nous sépare c'est le monde de
ce qui nous éloigne de l'origine de
l'origine divine
d'ailleurs sa part la main elle est
assez loin c'est-à-dire qu'il disait que
par exemple l'enseignement de la
conjugaison était quelque chose de
diabolique puisque la la variété des
pronoms personnels montrait bien et
d'une dissociation de l'être et qui
confirmait 7e cette fragmentation de
l'unité divine que lorsqu'on dit je
pense tu penses ils pensent nous pensons
et bien nous sommes en train de d'opérer
cette division de l'unité que c'est à
partir de là que le mal entre nous ça
peut se tenir remarquée puisque diable
diable ça signifie ce qui divise ce qui
sépare et si le serpent qui était dans
l'art de la connaissance et bien le
diable et bien son travail et des
d'opérer cette cette séparation et cette
division de l'homme avec lui-même et
avec l'évidence pur de son rapport
immédiat à l'être donc là je vais me
faire pour le coup l'avocat du diable la
connaissance tel qu'on en parle depuis
tout à l'heure c'est à dire la
connaissance comme cessation de
l'évidence ce pur
cette connaissance peut servir aussi
bien le bien que le mal la connaissance
se peut donner lieu à eux à la fois à la
médecine et aux armes
qu'est ce qui fait la différence entre
ces deux usages de la connaissance
mais là encore c'est le libre arbitre la
connaissance n'est pas les bas le mal
par essence elles et le mal dans ses
comptes
quand ce possible on ne reviendront
toujours à la question de la possibilité
qui chez l'homme correspond au libre
arbitre
sauf que ce libre arbitre n'est pas à
eux n'est pas un mouvement purement
aléatoire de la décision dans le mot
libre arbitre il n'y a pas seulement le
mot liberté il y a aussi le mot
d'arbitrage et l'arbitrage c'est là la
possibilité de juger d'une chose à
partir de son examen et à partir de
l'examen de ses conséquences
les conséquences ne sont pas
indépendantes de nos choix ont produit
les conséquences de nos actes et ont
fait le choix de produire ses
conséquences par exemple si je vais voir
quelqu'un dans la rue et puis que je me
met à l'insulter
mais je dois m'attendre à ce que s'il me
met une droite ça faisait partie des
conséquences prévisibles de mon choix et
c'est ce qu'on appelle tout simplement
la responsabilité être responsable c'est
s'attendre à ce que le réel répondent à
nos choix et les conséquences de nos
choix
ce sont simplement les réactions du
monde matériel à nos décisions
la responsabilité est donc une loi c'est
une loi humaine qui va de pair avec la
liberté à partir du moment où je choisis
de faire quelque chose j'engage ma
responsabilité j'assume les conséquences
de mon choix je les assume
nécessairement puisque je suis libre de
mes choix
ce qui veut dire que lorsque adam et eve
ont provoqué la pomme ils ont fait le
choix de la liberté puisqu'ils ont fait
le choix la transgression ils ont fait
le choix de ne pas obéir à
l'interdiction et du même coup ils ont
fait le choix de la responsabilité
ils ont fait le choix de répondre de
leurs actes et de faire l'expérience des
lois de la causalité de faire
l'expérience de la responsabilité dans
le rapport à la matière rappelez-vous
que schopenhauer on a expliqué que le
monde de la représentation
c'était le monde qui étaient soumis aux
lois de la causalité et aux lois de la
matière et du temps le monde de la
causalité ça signifie que chaque cause
produit un effet je suis donc le libre
d'agir comme je le souhaite d'être la
cause de ce que je souhaite mais la
conséquence
en revanche je ne décide pas elle est le
prolongement nécessaire et logique de
mes choix
en expérimentant la liberté
j'expérimente les lois de la cause ali
j'expérimente les effets que ma liberté
aura sur le monde et donc j'accepte ses
conséquences comme étant l' effet
nécessaire de ma liberté
le libre arbitre n'existe pas sans la
loi de la causalité
il n'y a pas de libre arbitre si je n'ai
pas de critère de jugement de mon action
est le critère de jugement de mon action
ce sont les conséquences de mes actions
sur le monde
la liberté donc rivés intégralement au
principe de causalité
je disais donc du point de vue biblique
la possibilité du mal était déjà le mal
puisque la connaissance du bien et du
mal signifie la possibilité de choisir
le mal le diable c'est celui qui offre
la possibilité du mal c'est le tentateur
mais considérer que la possibilité du
mal et déjà le mal c'est faire
abstraction du principe de libre arbitre
qui nous permet de vérifier par
l'expérience ce que seront les effets de
notre action si elle est mauvaise
c'est donc nié la possibilité de
l'humain d'apprendre de ses erreurs et
d'évoluer de s'améliorer et de
progresser ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'on ne peut pas condamner la liberté
sous prétexte que la liberté peut
conduire au mal alors précisément que la
liberté est rivé à la responsabilité et
que c'est par la responsabilité que nous
pouvons réorienter notre liberté de
manière à ne plus être dans le mal à
moins de considérer que l'on puisse
faire le mal en toute impunité
il faut accepter le fait que si on fait
le mal est bien on en subira les
conséquences
donc finalement qu'à apporter le serpent
adam et eve
c'est le serpent c'est le diable et que
le diable c'est celui qui divise bien
satan c'est aussi l'adversaire
l'adversaire c'est ce qui est adverse
c'est ce qui fait obstacle c'est ce qui
s'intercale et satan c'est celui qui
s'intercale entre eux entre les hommes
et la lumière la lumière divine la
lumière de l'éternel c'est celui qui
s'intercale entre dieu et l'homme pour
produire l'ombre de dieu voilà pourquoi
on parle souvent d'un du satanisme comme
d'une inversion des valeurs puisque le
diable c'est celui qui produit l'ombre
de dieu c'est-à-dire son versant négatif
les ténèbres les ténèbres et en le
versant négatif de la lumière
là encore on peut faire le parallèle
avec platon puisque le monde sensible
chez platon c'est la copie du monde
intelligible et c'est une copie qui
participe du monde intelligible tout en
en étant là la version dégradée et
corrompu mais attends c'est donc aussi
celui qui apporte la liberté et c'est
celui qui apporte la liberté dans la
souffrance puisque la liberté n'est
accessible que par la souffrance la
souffrance c'est le prix de la liberté à
travers la responsabilité le serpent
c'est le tentateur c'est celui qui
éveille la curiosité la curiosité c'est
l'attirance pour ce qu'on ne connaît pas
c'est l'attirance pour ce qu'on n'a pas
en soi
pour ce qui est séparé de nous donc la
curiosité c'est un c'est un mouvement
perpétuel de sortie hors de soi
il éveille cette curiosité mais ne la
crée pas la curiosité est déjà en adam
et eve avant qu'il ne rencontre le
serpent le serpent a donc été placé dans
le jardin des delles sachant que adam et
eve posséder en de la curiosité et cette
curiosité cette année l'an c'est un
mouvement de sortie hors de soi c'est
quelque chose de l'ordre du dynamique
c'est quelque chose qui matérialise
l'entrée d'adam et eve dans l'histoire
dans le monde à la temporalité le jardin
d'éden pouvant être considéré comme un
monde fixe le monde de l'éternel dans
lequel il n'y a pas d'histoire et la
rencontre avec le serpent va va impulser
l'entrée dans l'histoire l'entrée dans
la matière le mouvement dynamique de
l'homme qui après sa chute va chercher à
remonter en prenant conscience de sa
liberté en prenant conscience des
conséquences de ses actes en faisant
l'expérience de la souffrance de la mort
et de la responsabilité
l'existence matérielle est donc une
leçon et pas seulement au sens de
punition mais aussi au sens
d'enseignement l'éternel a donné une
leçon adam et eve
il les a plongés dans le monde de la
matière en leur disant mais puisque
voulais être libre
vous allez comprendre ce qu'est le prix
de la liberté vous allez pouvoir goûter
votre liberté et vous allez pouvoir
apprécier tout ce qu'elle implique l
appui que la responsabilité elle
implique la souffrance à l'impliquent le
travail et d'apprendre l'existence
puisque on apprend de la souffrance et
du travail
on apprend en analysant les conséquences
de nos actes on apprend en comprenant le
monde qui est autour de nous le péché
originel c'est donc le premier choix de
l'homme c'est le premier acte de liberté
de l'homme
adam et eve avait le choix entre obéir
ou transgresser mai obéir à quoi ils ne
pouvaient que désobéir puisqu'il
ignorait à quoi ils obéissaient on n'est
pas dans un état d'obéissance quand on
ignore ce qu'est la transgression en
transgressant adam et eve n'ont rien
transgresser ils ont réalisé leur libre
arbitre et il doit en assumer la
responsabilité
ils avaient été prévenus adam et eve ne
sont ni coupable ni innocent ils ont
simplement suivi ce mouvement intérieur
qui les portaient à sortir hors de soi
pour aller faire l'expérience de cette
liberté je faisais le parlais tout à
l'heure entre le le jardin d'éden et
l'état de nature chez rousseau et là
encore c'est exactement les mêmes
mécanismes qui sont à l'oeuvre dans dans
le récit de de ce passage de l'état de
nature à à l'état civil chez rousseau et
du jardin d'éden au monde de la matière
dans le mythe d'adam et eve l'expulsion
de jardin d'éden c'est l'expulsion de
l'état de nature puisque l'état de
nature c'est l'état où tout est donné à
l'homme et la chute dans dans l'état
civil où l'on doit cultiver la terre où
l'on doit travailler où l'on doit se
soucier de l'image et la représentation
c'est exactement la même chose qui se
produit pour adam et eve le jardin
d'éden et en l'état de nature
l'état civil étant le monde temporel et
de la matière et la culture étant le
moyen de recréer les conditions de
l'état de nature par le travail par la
science par la technique
ce qui veut dire que le travail c'est la
condition du rachat et du salut des
hommes après leurs pêchés dans le jardin
d'éden comme dans l'état de nature les
hommes vont tout ce qu'ils veulent ils
n'ont besoin de rien tout est à
profusion et le travail des pas
nécessaire le travail ne sert à rien
dans le monde matériel comme dans l'état
civil
le travail est nécessaire et c'est par
le travail qu'on peut regagner les
conditions de l'état de nature
c'est par le travail qu'on peut ré
accéder à ce à ce paradis originel dans
lequel tout était à profusion donc quoi
qu'il arrive les hommes se rachète par
là où ils ont péché par la chute dans
l'état de nature comme par le passage
dans l'état civil
l'homme fait son entrée dans l'histoire
il lutte pour la survie
il lutte pour les ressources selon les
principes de de la rareté
l'histoire étant l'histoire des luttes
la lutte c'est le moteur de l'histoire
pour sortir de l'histoire et revenir à
un âge d'or
j'ai fait le parallèle entre le jardin
d'éden et l'état de nature chez rousseau
mais on peut aussi faire le parallèle
avec l'existence intra utérine
c'est à dire qu adam et est semblable à
un foetus il n'a pas conscience du corps
il est dans l'unité avec son
environnement il est dans dans la fusion
immédiate avec sa mère il ne connaît
rien des divisions de la matière et
pourtant il va tomber dans la matière il
va vivre une chute il va être séparé de
l'unité de l'unité maternelle et à
mesure qu'il va s'éloigner de cette
origine et bien l'être humain va grandir
il va apprendre
il va acquérir de l'expérience il va se
forger un libre arbitre va exercer sa
liberté à bon escient par l'analyse des
causes et des effets et continuera
malgré tout d'éprouver la nostalgie du
paradis perdu et de la même façon que le
premier souffle du bébé à la naissance
est un cri un cri de souffrance eh bien
la chute de la matière est une
souffrance mais elle est une souffrance
qui va déboucher sur un apprentissage et
qui va déboucher sur l'acquisition de la
conscience
le bébé qui sort du ventre de sa mère
souffre mais personne ne s'émeut de
cette souffrance personnes et triste
personne ne pleure et pourtant ils sont
au front mais personne ne pleure parce
qu'on sait que c'est de ce souffle le
primordial que va naître l'apprentissage
et au fond c'est tout ce que cette
souffrance de la naissance est quelque
chose de nécessaire si on veut se donner
les moyens d'évoluer la souffrance
d'adam et eve étaient nécessaires s'il
voulait se donner les moyens d'évoluer à
dents ils sont ils coupables d'avoir été
corrompu par le serpent bien je dirais
que si l'on était corrompu c'est qu'ils
étaient corruptibles et que s'il était
corruptibles c'est qu'ils ont été créés
et corruptible le péché était prévu il
était nécessaire
pourquoi le serpent était-il là comment
at il pu s'adresser à m qui l'a laissé
entrer
d'ailleurs contre parle du péché
originel on peut l'entendre dans un
double sens le péché originel c'est le
péché d origine
c'est donc le péché au sens historique
le premier péché mais c'est peut-être
aussi le péché originel est originaire
ça signifie constitutif donc le péché
originel c'est peut-être le péché
structurelles
le péché sur lequel se font l'humanité
et dans ce cas là le péché n'est pas
liée à une forme de culpabilité le péché
c'est l'acte qui précède l'apprentissage
d'ailleurs je précise qu'il n'y a pas de
colère chez dieu lorsqu'il chasse adam
et eve du jardin d'éden
il n'ya pas d'affect dieu n'est pas en
colère je ne leur en veux pas ils sont
expulsés parce que ils avaient été
prévenus qu'ils seraient expulsés
s'il transgresser l'interdît si vous
goûtez dufry vous mourrez
ce n'était pas une bonnasse c'était un
avertissement vous avez goûté le fruit
vous avez donc ouvert la porte il va
vous mener à l'expérience de la matière
l'éternel a mis le désir et la curiosité
dans le coeur d'un dans rêves
il a mis le libre arbitre la jeunesse de
10 la femme vit que l'arbre était bon à
manger et agréable à vue et qu'il était
précieux pour rouvrir l'intelligence
lorsque adam et eve mange le fruit nous
est dit leurs yeux s'ouvrirent lorsque
s'ouvrir ça veut dire qu'ils ont des
yeux ici ils ont des yeux c'est pour
s'en servir
la faute doit être comprise mais elle
doit être comprise que par l'expérience
de la souffrance puisque prévenir ne
suffit pas on ne comprend pas les choses
les yeux fermés il ne suffit pas de
prévenir pour que l'on comprenne
il faut que l'on vive il faut que l'on
expérimente la faute pour avoir
conscience que c'est une faute
il faut que l'on vive et que l'on
expérimente les choses pour comprendre
ces choses
l'orgueil qui est la source du péché
doit être confronté à lui même et à ce
qu'il engendre
et s'il y a un orgueil dans cet acte de
liberté et bien l'orgueil sera confronté
à ses propres conséquence et c'est un
cycle individu pourra apprendre ce qui
veut dire que si adam et eve sont
coupables du péché d'orgueil et bien
c'était un défaut intentionnel l'orgueil
a été placée en eux pour les marquer du
sceau de la perfectibilité ils peuvent
s'améliorer
ils peuvent apprendre ils peuvent
évoluer parce qu'ils ont en eux ce qui
va les pousser à l'expérience
alors finalement est-ce que le serpent
n'a pas rendu service à adam et eve bien
directement non mais indirectement
peut-être c'était peut-être un mal pour
un bien
c'était peut-être une souffrance pour l
enseignement on sait que le serpent
c'est le symbole de l'ambivalence
c'est à la fois le poison est le remède
d'ailleurs le serpent figure sur le
symbole de la pharmacie les cas du cdj
ça peut nous évoquer la phrase de
paracelse tout est poison rien des
poisons on pourrait peut-être dire tout
est poison tout et remèdes et de la
façon qu'on peut considérer que la
connaissance ce peut être un poison dans
la mesure où elle nous fait sortir de
notre rapport immédiat lettres et bien
elle est peut-être aussi un remède elle
est peut-être aussi ce qui nous permet
de comprendre et de revenir à cet état
de fusion originel est unité avec son
pied l'unité de se comprend que
lorsqu'elle se divisent accéder au
paradis suppose d'avoir connu l'enfer et
peut-être que nous sommes en enfer et si
nous sommes en enfer ce n'est pas parce
que nous l'avons mérité ce n'est pas
parce que nous sommes des pêcheurs et
c'est parce que nous sommes faits pour
apprendre et si nous sommes tous
coupables bien nous sommes coupables de
la même chose qu adam et eve d'exercer
notre libre arbitre
[Musique]
et